hey guys what's up this is andrew for
trendsenses.com so in this video i would
like to go with you guys through uh
friday's price action on amc and
gamestop we're going to have a look at
the technicals at the different
scenarios we're also going to have a
look very important at the option market
and try to see what is the synthetic
short where uh those call options that
create a short interest for market
makers are coming from um which maturity
which is very important because it's
going to give us information about for
how long there's going to be this
pressure on market makers that create
this strong bullish momentum so let's
get into it
[Music]
all right so we start with amc so here
is you know
my kind of preferred scenario it's uh
the bullish case that is showing that
after this breakout that you know was
very helpful here very efficient we can
see that then we had this retest almost
perfect and a strong move up
so i think that this move up is a one
two three four five so if this is true
we need to have the fifth wave coming
soon so i mean next monday maybe tuesday
if it doesn't come
soon we need to reassess what is
happening here because for now we only
having one two three which is corrective
so as long as we don't have clearly five
waves up it's very hard for me to
confirm that we are uh going towards the
major target that is 130. we can see
that here for now so france was a bit of
boring day sprt and bbig the stocks that
everybody was looking at and i think
this has always been there but amc and
gme uh have a very solid fanbase that i
think that what is happening on the
other stocks won't affect the price
action uh on amc and jimmy because the
market cap is much much bigger we're
talking here about 20 billion us dollars
of market cap roughly for both of them
those small stocks that are squeezing
right now have 200 300 million market
cap so you can see that the flows that
go into the stocks are actually much
smaller than the flows that go to amc
and gme so
i don't think this would uh impact much
but the truth is that it was a quiet day
for amc and it was a busy day for those
smaller market caps that are squeezing
too so i'm not sure how to analyze this
but i'm still very convinced that this
quiz will happen on amc and gamestop
it's just a question of timing how to
say exactly when it was looking very
good now it's looking a bit less good
but it's still very bullish very
positive we don't have any bearish
signal for now on amc
uh let me quickly have a look at the
option market so amc them
okay take tech tag
all right let's refresh that
okay so here we go
16 of maximum synthetic short and eight
percent that is consumed right now
i'm surprised six percent on me let me
check maybe i have some issues with
volatility
yeah you see the 27th of august because
it has expired okay we we have an expiry
the 27th of august has expired so that's
why this is now smaller so you see if
those options are not rolled the bullish
momentum is going to disappear so we're
going to have a look at whether or not
the option uh interest is growing now on
amc that the 27th of august has expired
are those corruptions are going to be
ruled on the next maturities so we're
going to see that on monday and tuesday
but for now i don't see it
now let's try to see where the big
is you see the 40 strike call
okay and here
so we can see that the two biggest one
are the 40 and 100 uh strike call oh no
this one
the 145 is the biggest so let's see
where this is coming from so here 13 000
70 000 70 000 so it's coming from
everywhere okay jan 22 jan 23 september
so this is showing us that this bullish
momentum is here for long term because
options are here on the long term as
well let's have a look at gme for
example when i check the smallest one
like uh bbig and sprt you can have a
look guys in the video i posted
yesterday you can see that it's coming
from september and october so you know
the squeeze
it won't probably last as long as jimmy
and amc that are here for long term
squeeze you know it can squeeze once
squeeze again squeeze again you know
this can be a game that has no end as
long as shots don't fully cover gamestop
let's have a look
i'm gonna come right away to the chart
but let's check for now the option
interest so it's same what
no
this is not true
bam
i didn't refresh the strikes okay
here we go so same we had an expiry uh
so we we have six percent of synthetic
short seventeen percent of maximum
synthetic shots so you can see that we
have ten percent of gamma uh on the
upside you know because there is ten
percent of short created on the option
market whenever gamestop uh goes to
higher levels so let's do the same thing
so we know it's coming from the 800 950
so let's analyze what maturity are the
most used for this 950
okay so 19 000.
okay so it's coming from here
um
so this is gen 22 same thing guys so we
have here a lot of time i'm not saying
there's there's not going to be a
squeeze in september i'm just saying
that there can be one in september and
one and another one in december or jan
20 22 you know because
the positive uh effect created by the
option market
is here until at least
jan 22 and even gen 23 for amc so
these are long-term squeeze that are
gonna keep i think repeating uh as long
as shots don't fully cover now let's
have a look at the chart for gme so here
we have to me more strengths than on amc
you can see that the retracement here of
the third wave
is only 38.2 percent which is a typical
false wave uh as you guys know you just
type elliot wave frost and pressure pdf
bam you go on the first link and you go
to the page 79 i think
okay and you can see that uh here so
page 79 a typical false wave is
retracing do you see well
is retracing 38.2 percent for equal 38.2
percent of three okay so this is a
typical false wave keep this in mind
second waves they like to go to the 61.8
percent retracement and here this is the
rule i'm using for my targets four point
six one eight or one point six one eight
depending if the 56 extended on on or
not of one plus three okay it's not very
clear here you need to measure one plus
three okay so this is what i'm doing to
find my targets of 800 and 135 on amc at
100 for gamestop and 135 for mc but here
what i'm interested in is to see this
five waves moves up for now we only have
by the way three waves but you can see
that one two three and the force where
is the force going you measure the third
and you see that 38.2 so this is very
typical a shallow force wave
this look this is looking good for
fifths and the fifths i'm going to use
the other method so i measure one plus
three applied to the bottom of the force
and it's giving me uh so here um you see
so can can be everything can be 245 so
0.618 can be one to one 275 the most
likely one for me because i have here a
huge resistance or 330 if you know we
break out right away which would be of
course the signal very clear that we're
going to 800 all right so if you go to 3
30 next week i can tell you we're gonna
go higher because of the gamma that
we're having here and
this strong bullish momentum that we're
having on this stock so to conclude
let's see let's see gamestop looks a bit
stronger than amc but amc is looking
great too we are losing here a bit
momentum which i don't like but it's
still looking fine the option market is
looking very good
for those kind of huge market caps until
jan 22 gen 23 so we have time it looks
to me like something is gonna happen in
september uh but once again i need to
see five ways to you know have more
confidence in this scenario so i just
repeat the scenario we go to 70 we come
back to 55 and then we go to 130 so
that's it for me i hope you guys enjoyed
this video and if you did please don't
forget to click on the sub like and bell
button so you're going to be the first
to know when are you planning anything
new and stay close to shore see you guys